you can see people using their bare
hands using pickaxes just doing their
best to move the rubble to try to get to
what they believe are their relatives
still alive below this huge mound of
concrete this was once eight-story
building and there's a number of them
all in this area at the entrance to
Antarctica which appeared to have been
almost flattened you can see cars there
that are virtually buried
they're constantly going into these
holes that they're trying to create
these air pockets to try and talk to
people that keep on whistling to try and
attract attention many of the locals
here saying they haven't seen any real
official help and no heavy equipment to
try to get down to the concrete through
the concrete to rescue these people a
lot of very distraught relatives all
complaining that they have been
abandoned here